so you talked about the importance of
data science in analyzing
genomes and understanding
what's to come and then you also talked
about lifestyle choices
and looking at different omics like
genomics and proteomics and even
phonological and physiology so
in your view how would you see
critical aspects of incorporating
different types of omics in
understanding basic physiology
that relate to health yeah so there are
probably a lot of
different ways i could answer this i
mean i wouldn't just limit it to omics i
mean i wouldn't just limit it to
genomics and proteomics i mean i would
just sort of i would i would probably
cast it as there's
going to be all different kinds of data
that are
that will be generated or are available
i would throw in their
electronic health record data which
isn't even research data but it's
incredibly valuable
for research genomic data as better
technologies come for measuring proteins
it'll be proteomics and then
metabolomics and then glycomix and blah
blah
and as you know fitbits become you know
embedded
devices we will have ekgs of people 724
365
will have all sorts of you know they'll
just be immense amounts of data
you know just i could just sort of stop
at any one of these things and just
think about how much better it is to
have more data
than a single clinical measurement of
your blood pressure when you're and
you go see your physician you think
about all that data and all these things
it becomes a data science challenge i
think it's the reason why i think the
next speaker in this series is patty
brennan who's the
director of the national library
medicine and i'm sure she'll be talking
about data science because it's a big
part of what she and her
and her institute it's called lash
library medicine responsible for
you know underlying all of this is i i
think your generation
will absolutely do scientific inquiry in
a very different way than my generation
did
um i i think i've seen some of this
transition even when i had my lab i saw
the transition where all of a sudden
everybody early on was working at the
bench
and pipetting and then it's that was
like the 1990s and then by the beginning
of 2000 they were all at the computer
and even the way we wanted to design
labs here at nice has changed
and i think they're going to be
significant numbers of brilliant
scientists in your generation that will
never touch a pipettement
that i think will really be analyzing
all of these data because generating the
data is going to turn out to be very
easy
and we're working really hard to make
sure all this data is shareable so
everybody can access it
so i just think that's the most you know
some of these
incredibly exciting opportunities it's
just it's a very different way of doing
research
it won't be for everybody i don't mean
to imply nobody would be pipetting but i
just think the
center of gravity will be more on data
analysis than data generation